okay okay gut 321
die konstellation ist die folgende damit
ihr versteht was überhaupt hier abgeht
die leute hier sind im urlaub ja wir
sind im urlaub an der nordsee
wir haben hier so bisschen strenger
vermieter das video für eigentlich
umschreibt es folgen wir haben hinter
der kamera von kontrolle von macht heute
habe ich einen snapshot intro köln
spielt die ersten zehn sekunden von
irgend youtube video ab dass er sich
selbst raussuchen darf nimmt es dann mit
snapshot auf hellas war video darüber
machen wie gut wir wollten das video
eigentlich nur mit conan aufnehmen also
nicht mit konkreten ort konnten und dann
kam luca und christa seit dem trade also
auf jeden fall des konzeptes das konnte
ich irgendwie youtube-video auslässt es
zehn sekunden laufen die ersten 10 sieg
und die ersten zehn sekunden mit
snapshot auf lässt die rückwärts laufen
und spielt uns aus den vornehmlichen
erwarten
anhand des rückwärts gelaufen ersten
zehn sekunden erkennt welche youtuber
das ist knapp das mit relativ tricky
konnte ich würde mal sagen
klose wäre es wohl hier raus sie am
besten kurz um die ecke und hatte
dadurch wird das ganze machen übrigens
als best of green heißt wer zuerst drei
richtig erraten hat geworden der andere
muss ich dann meinen bedecken hingegen
ok ok wird
nikon hat jetzt die erste sekunde ich
konnte nicht mehr ziehen immer sein
iphone dürfte der karlsberg
konrad das nächste update es nicht
6 welchen tipp geben keine richten
youtuber also so ok alles mega bekanntes
kennt jeder in deutschland ist man dem
wochentag sich von dem bach und johann
plan
liga kennt jeder in deutschland möchte
zwar schwierig es war heftig leute eins
zu eins stehen uns in der chemie ist
erst jetzt schon ja
ich hab doch schon gesagt jetzt noch
gesagt klingt das beste ist christ aber
so kollege der iss aus dem reallife
kennt und wenn wir vor der kamera sind
sie werden noch 1000 x b in der
tschechien ist aber sondern ebenso wie
dieses eine kind aus dem disney land
regierte
okay leute von hat was es steht 2 zu 1
theoretisch wenn ich etwas sage dann ja
ja ich hab die anlage sagt diana wer die
an alle die diana oder diana ich halte
die anna ich will leute schauen euch
dieses logo an
ich lege meine hand ins feuer legen muss
ich habe als erstes die aber ich hab'
ich habe als erste die assistenten chris
conley kabarett ich denke eine zahl
wer näher dran ist gewinnt ja ich sag
sie kommt einfach 120 x 120 x 15
größeren damit gewonnen ist 122 die
große entscheidung max
dann abonniert doch komplexer vorschnell
oder welche videos auf der das will
die sache ist ich hab ja kein macbook
dann bekommst du aber meinen laptop
du musst jetzt alles kaufen also ich ihm
gehören als kaufen
ok alles klar leute wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder wo ich max wir
sind zum nächsten jahr wo ich max
macbook pro 15 zoll 25 14 14 sowie
karten kleines es dann ja